I guess we're anticipating somewhat  lighter traffic with the federal holiday  today so we have a moment to say howdy  to yesterday's Mojave Max desert  tortoise education program tour we  stopped at Darnell Elementary School way  up in the far Northwest uh talking with  the third graders about the desert  orders learning to respect protect and  enjoy our desert Miss Joyce the teacher  volunteer who gets transformed into a  tortoise so they learn the body parts Mr  Adam showing the kids that a desert  tortoise egg is the size of a ping-pong  ball and learn more about entering the  emergence contest at mojavemax.com